SPEAKER: Hello, and welcome.
During this session, we're going
to present an in-depth demo,
where we will build the
necessary infrastructure
to support a fairly
sophisticated scenario for EDA
workload Burst case,
from customers on on-prem
to Google Cloud.
There is a lot to cover,
so let's get started.
The idea behind
this demonstration
is to showcase
the Cloud benefits
for EDA customers
that consider to start
their journey to Cloud.
Specifically, to
highlight the features
such as Cloud elasticity,
flexibility, and scalability,
and the real value that Cloud
can bring to these companies,
which is a shorter
time to market.
The ability to access
much larger resource
pools in the Cloud
enables engineering teams
to compress the total time it
takes to complete their jobs.
And with EDA workloads
running in the Cloud,
these teams can perform more
design iterations per day,
and get these designs out
to the market much faster.
We are going to start off by
presenting this setup we've
used to create this demo.
We've tried to build a
simplified architecture,
and have tried to be as close
as possible to real world
EDA architectures used today
by some of our customers,
and to run a flow
that resembles the EDA
Burst to Cloud scenario.
This demo consists
of seven steps,
and we will go over each
one before diving in.
Going to start with on-prem
system preparations.
From on-prem Worker, we
will install and configure
the open beta, which
is an open-source,
general-purpose,
multi-threaded [? many ?]
core processor and
framework environment.
In our case, we're exploiting
it as an infrastructure that
is used to configure and run
simulations and, in particular,
will serve as a source for
configuration files that
will be used for
regression runs in GCP.
Next, we're going to deploy
to NetApp CVO instances
in GCP using Terraform,
and configure
the FlexCache relationships
between on-prem and GCP
environments.
We will configure a NetApp CVO1,
to act as both high performance
storage for the
workloads in the Cloud
and as a cache for open
[INAUDIBLE] configuration files
from on-premises.
To an EDA workload in the
Cloud, the configuration files
appear to be local.
And there is no need to mirror
all the tools and libraries
to the Cloud.
Get just the data you need,
where and when you need it.
We will configure the
NetApp CVO2 instance
as a target for the Cloud
regression run results.
And by creating a reverse
cache relationship,
these results appear to
be local to engineers
working on on-prem.
During this step, we are going
to create a SLURM cluster.
Later on, we will use
special arguments that
are provided to the
regression run command,
and launch each test
in a SLURM [INAUDIBLE],,
allowing for tests to
be run in parallel.
Here, we will run
two regression runs.
First we'll be using
10 GCP Workers,
and the second will
use 20 GCP Workers.
The goal will be to
present the effect
of compute scaling and
the FlexCache technology
implementation.
Next, we're going to
present one of the benefits
behind the FlexCache.
We will showcase the ability
to access the same files
from both on-prem
and GCP Environments
by going over the
regression runs results
from both locations.
Going forward we will
demonstrate a case
where this regression
runs results
can be copied to Google
Cloud Storage for later
on analysis or archiving.
And the last step will be
the GCP Environment clean up.
We will delete it all and
remain with the regression run
results in GCS.
So let's dive into the demo.
As it was presented
before, we're
starting with on-prem
environment configuration.
As you can see here, we're using
the NetApp hardware storage
system.
From the on-prem
Worker, pre-mounted
to the on-prem volume, we
are installing the open pit
environment, while created
configuration files
will be used as a source for the
future regression runs in GCP.
We switch over to
the GCP environment,
where we will deploy to NetApp
CVO instances using Terraform,
followed by the FlexCache
relationships configuration.
We're starting with
the clear environment.
And through connection
to the Bastion host,
we are verifying the
correctness of [INAUDIBLE]
from configuration and starting
the deployment process.
After executing the
deployment, the progress
can be monitored through NetApp
Cloud management interface
And once it completes, we've
got the relevant information
that will be used in the
next steps of the demo.
By refreshing Google
Cloud console window,
we can see two new GCE
instances are created.
Having completed
the CVOs deployment,
we are going right in and
creating the FlexCache
relationships.
First, we will
create the connection
where the on-prem volume
will serve as a source,
and the CVO1 will be configured
with the FlexCache volume.
To speed up the
configuration process,
we will use a simple
pattern script
that utilizes the
NetApp on-top REST API
comments to preparing
the [INAUDIBLE]
to FlexCache relationship.
We insert the required
information about both source
and target NetApp systems,
and execute the script.
Once it's done,
we are continuing
with what is called a Burst
caching configuration, where
the CVO2 volume will
be used as a source,
and the on-prem NetApp
system will be configured
with the FlexCache volume.
We will use the same method
of executing the configuration
through the prepared
head-of-the-time script.
We can verify the
successful configuration
by accessing the on-prem
Worker and trying
to mount it to created-a minute
ago on-prem FlexCache volume.
Having enabled the
FlexCache relationships,
we're heading in deploying
the SLURM Workload Manager.
This manager will be
used to orchestrate over
the regression runs in GCP.
The link to SLURM
deployment files
can be found in the comments
below or in the demo
walkthrough documentation.
The SLURM will be
deployed using Terraform.
So we switch over to
the configuration file,
and update it with all the
relevant information required
for the deployment.
Again, all the information
can be found in the demo
walkthrough documentation.
It takes a couple of minutes for
the installation to complete.
We can see the new SLURM
instances are created
in our project and it will
take additional 15 minutes
for the deployment
process to complete.
While waiting for the SLURM
deployment completion,
we're going to create
performance dashboards,
using Google Cloud Monitoring.
The goal is to be
able to follow the IO
Flow during the regression runs,
and present the NetApp CVOs
read-write throughputs.
We can verify SLURM deployment's
successful completion
by connecting to the
SLURM Log In-Out.
It's mounted to
both NetApp CVOs.
We can access on-prem data
using FlexCache and SLURM
nodes are ready to be
allocated to run the workload.
Now, we are ready to
execute the aggression runs.
First we will be
using 10 Workers
and then we'll perform the
same, but scaling the Workers
from 10 to 20.
Each regression run
will include 46 tests.
The run will be started
from the SLUM Log In-Out
And once started, it
will require the access
to relevant configuration files,
which are currently located
at on-prem NetApp volume.
Once these files are
cached locally in GCP,
SLURM Batch job has started,
allowing for regression tests
to be run in parallel.
New regression run
results directories
created at CVO2 and 10
new computing instances
are created in our project.
And now let's
monitor the IO Flow.
Newly created Workers are
mounting to both NetApp CVO
instances, and reading
the run configuration data
through CVO1.
Since the data is not
presented locally,
it is fetched from
on-prem volume.
Of course, all
that is completely
transparent to the workers
running the test in GCP,
and the configuration files
appear for them to be local.
We can see that the Worker
CPU [? transition ?]
is getting higher once they're
starting to run the test.
And the test results
are written back
to dedicated volume created
at NetApp CVO2 instance.
Once we are done with
the first regression run,
we want to verify
that the results
folder is accessible for both
GCP and on-prem environments.
First, we are accessing the
results folder located at CVO2
from GCP instance.
And as you can see, there is
a list of the completed tests.
Now, using the FlexCache, we can
access exactly the same folder
from on-prem Worker, and
can read any of the files
from there.
Before we continue
to the next step,
we can refresh the Google
Cloud Console window,
and we can see that
all the 10 Workers
are deleted automatically by
SLURM upon job completion.
And now, we will execute
the same regression run,
but this time with 20
instead of 10 Workers.
The first step will be to
update the SLURM configuration
and validate it.
We're changing the
number of Workers
to be deployed from 10 to 20.
[? End ?] validating, the
configuration is saved.
Starting a new job right now.
The new run starts
quicker, since the part
of the configuration files
already cached and located
locally in the Cloud.
Once a new job is started, we
can see that the new regression
run results directory
is created at CVO2,
and 20 new compute instances
are created at our project.
While monitoring
the IO Flow, we can
identify pretty much
the same behaviors
as we did with the first run.
But this time, much
less data is fetched
from on-prem environment, since
it's already partially cached
in the Cloud.
Workers maximum read
throughput is twice higher
than with previous run.
And while writing back the
results to CVO2 instance,
the overall max
throughput is higher.
All that happens because we
have now twice Workers running
the same workload in parallel.
This run completes much
faster in comparison
to the first attempt.
The time savings are very clear.
And again, as with previous
run, we can validate it.
All the results
can be accessible
for the further analysis
from both environments--
GCP and the on-prem.
By refreshing all Google
Cloud Console window,
we can verify that all the
Workers are deleted again
by the SLURM automatically upon
the completion of the test.
Now, when we have all
the results in the GCP,
we can move it to a less
expensive storage option, where
it can be accessed later on
for further analysis or just
being archived.
We're creating new GCS bucket
and copying both results
directories there.
Once copied, it can be accessed
through Google Cloud Console
or by any other available means.
Having done all that, and
assuming that we currently
don't need anything else from
our Cloud Infrastructure,
we can go ahead
and clean it all.
After deleting the
FlexCache configuration,
we proceed to deleting the
NetApp CVOs using Terraform.
While we're running that, we
can destroy SLURM deployment
as well, again, by
using the Terraform.
Once everything is
completed, we can
see that our GCP
project is empty,
and our regression runs
results are still remaining
for access through GCS.